je n'ai pas encore lu i canard enchaîné
mais j'ai vu effectivement les
principaux titres du canard enchaîné qui
nous annonce si je comprends bien que
sur une période plus longue
elle a gagné plus d'argent paraît assez
logique que quand on a travaillé non pas
huit ans mes 15 ans on est tous est
effectivement en cumulé une somme plus
importante
gilles a rien nouveau me semble-t-il par
rapport à tout ça la vraie question qui
est posée à françois et a peiné
l'appuyons par le canard enchaîné et
aujourd'hui par la justice et cet emploi
est est il un emploi fictif
où était-il l'emploi de la femme de
françois fillon qui travaillait
effectivement pour françois fillon il ya
une procédure judiciaire qui a commencé
françois fillon défend évidemment son
honneur et son épouse devant les
magistrats ou plutôt devant les
policiers en affirmant qu'il s'agissait
effectivement d'un va et emploi et pas
non pas fictif
j'ai évidemment la conviction que
françois fillon a raison qu'il se
défendra et que la justice lui donnera
raison